I'm not leaving because it was hard
had that been the case I probably would
have departed two months into the job
I am leaving
because with such a privileged role
comes responsibility
the responsibility to know when you are
the right person to lead and also when
you are not
I know what this job takes and I know
that I no longer have enough in the tank
to do it justice
it's that simple
Nicole standing by for is in Sydney this
morning she was on the edge of Tears um
not running in the election she would
probably have lost anyway wouldn't she
it certainly looked like it was going to
be a close election because jacinderella
Jones popularity domestically has been
waning over the last few months and
along with her popularity that of her
party the labor party many new
zealanders have been frustrated and fed
up with the same sorts of economic
issues that are affecting the whole
world rising in flashing it's soaring
cost of living and High house prices so
her popularity was on the Wane but
internationally she'll still be
remembered and renowned for having a
real star a pulling power effectively
she really put New Zealand on the sort
of diplomatic map
especially after the Christ Church
attack that was the massacre in 2019 51
people killed in Christchurch shot dead
Jacinda Arjun really handled herself
with a great deal of empathy the grace
and composure during that those images
were broadcast around the world of her
comforting fellow new zealanders wearing
a head scarf but it has come as a big
shock to new zealanders that she has
decided to pull out this Sunday the
labor caucus will vote for a new prime
minister and leader and all of this will
lead up to a general election to be held
in October